كما قال مراسلون الحرب مستمره اسرائيل
ابلغت مصر بوقف محادثات التهدئه وذلك بحجه
توسيع نطاق الصواريخ من غلاف غزه لتصل الى
مستوطنات القدس والضفه الغربيه مع العلم
انها ليست المره الاولى التي تقصف فيها
مناطق بهذا البعد خلال هذه العمليه تحديدا
يعني هذا التطور البارز سنبدا به كما قالت
فيدا تحدث مراسلنا قبل قليل عن اطلاق
صواريخ بعيده المدى من جديد نتحدث عن
صواريخ تقريبا بمدى يصل الى 75 كم اطلقت
هذه الصواريخ باتجاه مستوطنات جنوب وغرب
القدس المحتله وفقا لشبكه لشبكه مراسلينا
دوت صافرات الانذار في كل هذه المناطق في
حتى في مستوطنات الضفه الغربيه المحتله في
غرب بيت لحم في غوش عطسيون كذلك في
مستوطنه بيطار عليت وايضا في هذه المناطق
في محيط بيتشيمش طبعا تتحدث
عن اعتراض صاروخ فوق
الجبال الجنوبيه للقدس المحتله الاعتراض
كان بمنظومه مقلاع داوود التي تتحدث
اسرائيل عن استخدامها للمره الثانيه هنا
الان في هذه المناطق طبعا الى جانب القبه
الحديديه للتعامل طبعا مع اعداد الصواريخ
الكبيره ولا سيما طويله المدى التي يتم
اطلاقها من قبل الفصائل الفلسطينيه طبعا
سبق كما ذكرنا ان اعترضت اعترضت هذه
المنظومه صواريخ اخرى جنوب تل ابيب في
اليوم الاول للعمليه كذلك اعترض اعترض
صاروخ اخر في بيت شيمش بالقبه الحديديه
اليوم كما اشرنا بالعموم يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان له ان اداء القبه
الحديديه وكما ذكر الياس قبل قليل في
اعتراض الصواريخ وصل الى 91% طبعا هذا
الاعلان يتزامن اليوم مع اعلان اخر لفتح
تحقيق حول خلل
بسبب الصواريخ طبعا وفي اشكول اطلقت حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي اكثر من عشرين صاروخا
بشكل متزامن الى هذا المجمع هنا المقابل
لمعبر كرم ابو سالم جنوب قطاع غزه اصابت
احدى هذه الصواريخ بشكل مباشر منشاه
زراعيه هناك كذلك كانت صافرات الانذار
تدوي في معظم هذه المناطق نيراوز عينها
كل هذه المناطق طبعا وطبعا هذه المناطق
كما اشرنا اكثر من مره ما زالت كلها تشهد
اغلاق حركه مروريه كذلك وقف المدارس
والتجمعات في نطاق حوالي اربعين كيلو متر
في مقابل هذا يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
قصف نحو
2005 عشر موقعا داخل قطاع غزه قال انها
تابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في قطاع غزال
مناطق التي تم قصفها في الساعات الاخيره
منزل في دير البلح
دمرته المقاتلات الاسرائيليه بشكل كامل
لكن طبعا دون اصابات ليكون هذا رابع منزل
تدمره اسرائيل في غزه بشكل كامل هذا اليوم
كما ذكر وائل الدحدوح كذلك طال القصف اراض
زراعيه في بيت حانون هنا كذلك في شرق خان
يونس في مخيم النصيرات ايضا كان هناك قصف
كذا كما قصف الطائرات الاحتلال شرق رفح
وزعمت ان احد مواقع القصف يتبع لقائد
كتيبه رفح في الجهاد الاسلامي في الوقت
نفسه تستمر عمليات الاستطلاع المكثف التي
تقوم بها مسيرات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على كامل حدود قطاع غزه وكما ذكر وائل قبل
قليل هذه الاستطلاعات عاده تستخدم لرصد
منصات اطلاق الصواريخ في قطاع غ